[موسيقى]
سوق الملحاني في منطقه الكاظميه الى جانب
الكرخ من العاصمه بغداد
هنا تحديدا يوجد صانع الاثاث الماخوذ عن
سعف النخيل او الجريد كما يسمى محليا ابو
عباس واحد ممن احترفوا هذه المهنه
ورثها عن ابائه واجداده في محافظه ديالى
وامتهنها حتى يومنا هذا
هذا الشيوخ قديم من زمان يعني اني جيت
بهذا السوق بسنه الالفين اجيت هنايا وهذا
السوق موجود قبلي يعني من الزمن ابويا
واني طفل عمري حوالي خمس سنين ست سنين او
يعمل بالهويدر هي موجود هاي الشغله عشان
ما تلقى الناصريه بعدين قام يجيبون جاهز
من الناصريه بالنسبه للقصر اما بالنسبه
انه نشتغل بالسعاف هي هاي شغلتنا من زمان
موجودين هنايا واللي قبلي اكو ناس بطله
تركت المصلحه واكو ناس بعد
يستخدموا ابو عباس سعف النخيل راقبا قبل
تجفيفه وبعد ثقبه باداه
ثم يدخل سعفا جففه وقطعه باشكال منتظمه في
هذه الثقوب صانعا بذلك كراسي وطاولات
واقفاصا واسره من جريد النخيل
اختصاص يشتغلون بالسعر
اختصاص ياخذوه يجيبون
من الورق بعدين يجيبوه انه السعه الاخضر
اللي هو يتثاقب قابل للتثقيب يعني شغلنا
كله يدوي يعني من الثقب السعف بالسنبه
يدوي
لم تتدخل المكائن في هذه الصناعه وبقيه
المهنه خاضعه للجهد اليدوي باستخدام معدات
بسيطه مثل منشار الخشب والدقه والساطور
والسمبا وبالرغم من انحسار الاقبال على
هذا السوق لكن هنالك طلبا كبيرا على هذا
النوع من الاثاث لتجهيز الاماكن الترفيهيه
التي تعنى بالموروث الشعبي العراقي في
اطلالتها زينب المشاط صباح العربيه بغداد